so guys fast right really fast it's a
very very cool super hot power to have
but somehow I think that the Flash's
powers might meeting that was cool
somehow I think that the Flash's powers
might be negated at comic-con because
absolutely nothing moves fast at
comic-con with 150,000 people in your
way
please welcome varieties Laura Pritam
who's feeling the need for speed tonight
I am varieties Laura put'em that is true
it is my pleasure to welcome you to the
flash portion of this very Super
Saturday night and we've got a lot to
talk about clearly so without further
ado I'm going to bring out the cast and
executive producers of this amazing show
to start with executive producer Andrew
Kreisberg executive producer Greg
Valenti
Joe John Wesley Shipp stark Angus patent
just yell Martin Grant Gustin Tom
Cavanaugh danielle panabaker Carlos
vatos
and DC chief creative officer jeffchang
welcome guys do we all like what we just
saw so uh Andrew Greg Jeff whoever wants
to take it what the hell do we just see
explain George what is coming up in
season two what can we look forward to
uh well our big bad this season is gonna
be zoom which we're very excited about
um he's gonna be faster than the
reverse-flash faster than the flash and
it's gonna be very hard to catch him um
you were also introducing Jay Garrick to
the show this year um we're very excited
we have Teddy Sears from masters of sex
playing him cool um and we're also
adding a patty spivot uh to the show
who's another big comic book character
who's gonna be played by Chantal van
Statten from the messengers whoa whoa
right and our world so um we're also
gonna be adding Wally West my work here
is done
uh well we left season 1 off with you
guys opening a wormhole over Central
City so then you left us hanging for
months ah so the only old logical place
to start this panel is to ask where on
Infinite Earths are we gonna start
season 2 chief you can do it we we pick
up a few months later and I you know I
don't want to give too much away because
I want everybody to enjoy the episode
when you get a chance to see it but we
do we deal with very much sort of just
the fallout of the Cataclysm that
happened at the end of the year you know
as we use the particle accelerator in
the explosion last year to introduce
metahumans to the DC Universe on
television this year we'll be
introducing characters from earth-2 and
that's obviously the origin of Jay and
we'll be dealing with earth 2 on the
show and get a chance to tell those
kinds of stories very nice uh
let's start with you okay how would you
say the events of the finale have
changed Barry going into season two
where do we find him when we pick him we
find Barry dealing with some extra
attention
I guess specifically on the flash and
just kind of being treated as the hero
for central city and it's kind of he's
having a hard time accepting that role
it's weighing kind of heavily on him
just because he knows and the audience
knows that Eddie was ultimately the hero
that stopped Welles and the finale and
ultimately saved everybody so I think
Barry that we're finding him kind of
struggling with his role as a hero I
guess and he's kind of a lone wolf at
this point we're working on his own and
doesn't want anyone else to get hurt
trusting call us mm-hmm in the finale
Cisco may have discovered something
pretty important about himself that you
didn't know before
courtesy of well something that fans
might be excited about perhaps it may be
selective time how will that inform his
Johnny and Susan - what can you preview
about where we find Cisco well I think
as viewers saw in the latter half of
season 1 Cisco I start seeing these
visions having these dreams
he starts undergoing these sort of
biological changes that take place in
his brain basically in his mind and
those kind of augment themselves over
time and yeah I think the beginning of
season 2 deals a lot with how Cisco
deals with that change and also deals
with what a eobard thawne told him at
the end of season 1 and the
repercussions of was he telling the
truth what is he talking about
but foremost you know changes in his
body for sure not puberty
though he does look 12 uh Jessie all the
way down that hmm
Jessie job Jess oh yeah no Jessie Elmo
Jenna Jesse's actually Jesse L Martin is
actually not here he's he's recovering
from a uh I can retain majestic if it's
not sick in the stomach um her uh well
producers can we talk a little bit about
why jay garrick why did you feel like
this was the right time to introduce him
um you know jay garrick is obviously you
know integral to the the flash mythology
he was the original flash and um you
know he's never really been portrayed
and to our knowledge and live action and
you know now that we've established you
know our flash we thought it was
interesting to bring on you know the
original flash and create a brand new
relationship for Barry to have and we're
just we're super excited about it it's
it's actually pretty weird the episode
number flash 123 where his helmet was
introduced is actually the number of the
flash comic where Barry Allen met Jay
Garrick we should Andrew and I thought
very strange but cool destiny
I'm very geeky Candice now iris finally
knows Barry secret yes thank finally
finally yes so how does that kind of
alter Peres her interest in documenting
the Flash's adventures in season two
what are we gonna see kind of from a
journalistic standpoint next season yeah
I think immediately we're gonna see iris
kind of have a new sense of agency and
you know we've begun shooting season one
and already I find myself often in STAR
Labs so I think it's very safe to say
that iris is going to be a part of the
flash team and some some aspect which i
think is really cool she's very smart
and very intelligent and she has her own
way of adding to the team I always say
that you know Cisco and Caitlin are the
science and the tech behind what's
happening at STAR Labs and with flash
and and iris is more of heart and earth
she can she can navigate central city
and talk to people in the streets and
really get stories out of people that
maybe you know other people can't get so
it's gonna be interesting to see how she
uses her knowledge on the streets to
help you help team flash thing uh-huh
well John yes Henry advised Barry
against changing time he's obviously you
know that's hero heroism obviously runs
in the family
hmm but what what is he gonna be doing
in season two is anyone gonna be kind of
taking on his case is he gonna catch a
break at this point what can you
previous well certainly a large part of
Barry's life and season one was was
trying to spring henry from prison was
unsuccessful in doing it in season one
and and i certainly will be addressed in
season two in one way or another I mean
eventually Henry will get out we don't
know how or what and one way or another
you know or more will be revealed about
that wonderful we're gonna start taking
audience questions in just a minute if
you want to start lining up for that we
want to get a couple of years in uh Tom
well that's my that's my family yeah
guys for coming all the way it's great
to see you really happier here got a
large family were all family here hmm
well last season you obviously knew
Thorne's grand master scheme from the
start unlike the rest of us so in season
two what can you say about getting to
know the real Harrison wells well last
season uh was uh it was absolutely
tremendous it was you know eating steak
not a Tater Tot you know it was like it
was just that's my food analogy thank
you that's only my family laughter that
one that's like he likes to eat food um
meanwhile back at the question it was
really enjoyable to do that I think we
the writers did a tremendous job
fashioning a character that got to play
good and bad play two levels and I think
we're very much interested in continuing
that kind of duality as we go forth and
in season two hey Danielle thank you I
love you guys too
Caitlin is the newly married woman but
uh arguably and even bigger development
that we saw in the finale was a little
sneak peek of something there's a little
frosty no little chilly you did so uh
where do we find out when we kick off
season two and more importantly how did
it feel to put on that killer costume oh
I'm so excited for season two I mean I'm
beyond excited to hopefully get to
actually be killer frost one day as I
look to my bosses with it wink uh it's I
mean we worked really hard on that look
you know the the costume the wig the
makeup the contacts the whole thing so
I'm excited to see her more often
hopefully
all right let's check it to some
audience questions here's out there
where are you where are we looking over
here with spotlight please go hey guys I
Hey
thank you all for the amazing show
you're making you know it's great a lot
of love for it I actually come from
Russia a lot of love for you guys Wow my
question is about the Rogues
I know mr. Jones loves them so are you
guys going to use any more rogues in
season 2 and who do you like to see in
season 2 as you know the villain for the
flash thank you I will be definitely
having you know adding to the rogues
gallery you know we've got a lot of
returning favorites
you know grodd's gonna be back we also
have a big Captain Cold golden glider
episode early on we'll be getting to
find out a little bit more about the
snark family dynamic but you know we've
got we've got a couple of villains we
don't want to share but uh yet but we're
really excited about zoom I think that
you know uh you know I think how that
presents and the challenges it brings to
our characters is gonna be uh you know
it's you know he's gonna be terrifying
and scary and fast then it's gonna be
really cool
the next question happy flash
appreciation day um I have a question
about episode 9 with the man the yellow
suit okay they explain how he can do a
mirage of some sort well how did he beat
himself up yeah guy he's that good
he's big Tom sorry was the last part of
it how does he beat himself up beat
himself up
good cuz beam himself up didn't make any
sense to me
like you got it wrong panel bro um it's
a speed it's a speed Mirage in other
words it moves so fast it leaves a
residue of itself standing behind while
he isn't actually in another in another
place that's the science behind I could
get really specific when we'd be here
for a but good about a good hour I hope
that's - oh you're like yeah you want to
hear it okay so um TomTom No
uh I think this might be a last question
because it's a hang are you kidding oh
sorry just got here I know maybe we can
get to it yes - last question and this
guy started cheering yeah isn't in your
food with me all right time my name is
Cameron suck um this is for Carlos whoa
Vai become vote people he become vaad
next season uh I'm Andrew
Candace grant not sure here's your
answer actually if you want if you want
if you want to know more about what
Carlos Dustin how it interacts with
earth - but Andrew and I wrote vibe for
a while and his powers and how it
relates to the multiverse are it's all
in the comic yeah the comic is dope
sterling gates Jeff Jones Andrew
Kreisberg anyway are you working on your
break dancing and that's it they're
wrapping us I'm so sorry
give it up for the flash panel
you